we are heading into cold and flu season  so check your medicine cabinets though  some of your medication might actually  be out of date doctors say taking  expired medication is just not safe the  food and drug administration says  changes in expired medications chemical  structure can really be dangerous  sometimes medications become less  effective when they're out of date but  they could also be more effective  so if you have expired medications there  are plenty of ways to safely get rid of  them there are take back kiosks at your  local pharmacy a lot of them you can  also visit a location on national  prescription drug take back day and  that's october 23rd